I was with McCone um Jesse Johnson and I
was with
Carlos Herrera
and the host just looks up at me
she's probably a 55 year old woman
she she does a little smirk and then she
goes
Harold oh no what come on
I look at Macon right who's this kid
videographer that we have and he blushes
and I'm like I I was shell shocked
because I haven't witnessed that since
the 80s right like a blatant you know
man
and then we sit down and then often the
waiter comes up I'm a big fan of you
from Mad TV
right and then I see hero lady right
people going back oh Bobby Lee's here
they said and I could see her kind of
just shuffling things around like maybe
I [__] up or whatever but it was such
a bold what what are you looking at
nothing I'm imagining no no no no
honestly I think you feel you're a
little bitty eye your little Yoda eyes I
know I know what Yoda did on Dagobah all
right hey right and he would do this
little BDS thing about you know the
swamp soup right but you're reading too
much into things your storytelling is so
good I'm picturing everything right now
so picturing everything you are yes
this guy is [__] crafty shut the [__]
up him
I like you but shut the [__] up girl oh
you're [__] mouth just tell me what
happened with the lady my point is is
that what would you do if that happened
I mean if they're old I'm not saying old
people get a pass but what am I gonna do
is sock an old lady in the face you know
what I mean and come here for a second
you know knock her out was she like was
she laughing is she like was she like I
made a clever joke was she number one
she doesn't use the internet number two
she's old as [__] and she lives in
Tennessee what's the point and that's
why I didn't say anything yeah but how
on a scale of one to ten like how
offended were you really because you
called me and you were like laughing
okay and you loved it
you're gonna get somebody hair rolls at
restaurants
I do like it because it's old school
it's like yeah it's like when you're in
a mall you're listening to Earth Wind
and Fire yeah
yeah yeah yeah a classic the classic
right so it's like um
so in that way it was cool because it
was a classic yeah right also because
you know when I I'm older than you guys
so I I knew a day when that was just
standard every day you know I mean
microaggressions yeah yeah and then all
of a sudden the culture got stopped and
you know I mean you guys started rising
and no more Heroes right it still
happens obviously you depending like
you've you've experienced racism yes
where uh I was at a college show in
Upstate New York and we had finished the
show Oneonta I forget what in college it
was and I was walking back with a couple
just like the girls that put on the show
they're walking back to my uh my my room
and there's some drunk Fat Boys whites
were stumbling back and they saw me with
these two Asian girls and the guy goes
hey guys the Great Wall is that way and
I was so like that joke I didn't even
know what I was because I yeah that was
probably one of my first times just
dealing with it like that yeah and I
just I didn't know what to say hello
it's a classic it's like the eagles
game on Hotel California Hotel
California
[Laughter]
wow
so what'd you do I just um I just got
like what the [__] and then they
stumbled off and we well that's what
happens a lot we had a threesome and
that was my night
the wall is that way but you know when
stuff like that happens everybody is
braver in their mind than what they
actually do yeah because you just you
can't process it in the moment I'm not
sure have you guys ever done this where
somebody has something said something so
offensive to you and then you kind of
don't know what's going on and then
you're in the car then you just go hey
you
have plenty of time
you're laying in bed oh [__] you man not
loud and you're I mean whoever's next
year what the [__] is going on exactly
so everybody's always Brave in their
story first right and there has been
times where I have said something but
most of the time I'm just trying to
process it because it doesn't happen
every day it happens every day then you
can prep yourself for it right but
somebody goes the Great Walls that way
you just go
all right are you okay yeah yeah I wake
up in the middle name like the Great
Wall you
[Laughter]
go fast I like let's find a report for
that right now yeah and in fact let's
write a book on all our retards from
racist [__] from Asian race because I
can't think of it at the time because
your emotion plays into it rage and
whatever it might be so but there's so
many variations Great Wall is that way
what do we say well then I go oh I know
no yeah
you play into it you have to you go no I
know what else oh Chopstick oh yeah oh
no oh you go where are my Rickshaw yeah
if we go now we'll go now you know it
then you're playing into it but then
when they start laughing you say your
mom's house was that way I just left
from having sex with her oh
so let's Okay so let's go let's go let's
play it out okay I need to see it live I
want to see it live right now okay hey
hey the Great Walls that way oh yeah
well your mom's house is that way we
just had sex
whoa that bird rough sex rough
you go go crazy here in the anus yeah
raw raw and I ejaculated inside her all
right
well that guy took it too far wow yeah
all right so um how about the hero how
about the hero let's go back to her
wrong yeah it's a simple one so hero so
I go how are all how you doing um
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you're right so go let's see
if that works go hero hello
[Music]
um Goodbye Oh yeah you said goodbye go
by and then leave but I feel I feel this
way too A lot of people will do that to
you guys mainly because you guys are
smaller like the bigger the person is
saying bad things all the time today no
no no okay explain my thoughts replay
the clip earlier have you noticed the
tall Asian or elitists uh yeah they make
fun of the average size guys nice skin
tall [__] Asian yeah
Yoda eyes yeah
is
what I'm saying is that people will
always try to pick on somebody who
physically looked like they could just
bully you know they could bully me way
easier than you two I'm just taller you
know I you know I tend to believe you
I really do because if you I bet you Yao
Ming's never gotten anything racist yeah
he's so tall I don't know you I mean
even if you walked into a clan rally
they'd be like oh hey man don't say
nothing he'll kill everybody here well I
think he might get hit with the hero
because I don't know if she necessarily
meant any ill like you know she wasn't
trying to hurt your feelings right you
wouldn't hear it he's like so far
[Laughter]
do you ever wish that you were uh taller
when you were younger yeah very much so
thank you did you try to do anything to
make yourself talk no because I'm I have
common sense I looked at my parents like
I'm [__] like when your parents are
five one five one because your parents
could have been like malnourished and
maybe I've seen the whole family
there are not that sure that's not true
yeah